and it's a waiting game one unlv  professor says russia's next step could  determine the danger that lies ahead  professor paul worth says all eyes are  on russia right now and it's moved to  either take control of rebel territories  or ukraine itself he believes russian  president vladimir putin is acting as if  democracy in the west and around the  world is on the ropes with events like  the january 6 insurrection and the  abandonment of afghanistan last summer  seems to me that it really is um in a  lot of ways a dangerous moment and it  could very well be that we will look  back  on this moment as a very very important  shift in the way that geopolitics are  actually conducted  in in the world in a lot of ways it  feels as though the post-world war ii  order  is at least partially disintegrating  well he says there is no doubt there  would also be a high cost in military  expenses for russia if they choose to  invade